i'm going to define a function s
of n
and i'm going to define it as the sum
the sum of all
positive integers
integers
including n
including
including n and so the domain of this
function is really all positive integers
and has to be a positive integer and so
we can try it out with a few things we
could take
s of three this is going to be equal to
one plus two plus three which is equal
to six
we could take s of let's take s of four
well that's going to be one plus 2 plus
plus 4 which is going to be equal to 10.
so fairly fairly straightforward now
what i want to do in this video is prove
to you and there's actually multiple
ways to prove this that i can write this
as a function of n
that the sum of all the positive
integers up to and including n is equal
to n
times n plus 1
all of that over 2. and the way i'm
going to prove it to you or at least the
first way i'm going to prove it to you
is by induction this will be a proof
by
induction it's kind of an interesting
philosophical way to prove something
because the way you do a proof by an
induction is first you prove the base
case
you prove the base case so in the case
of this this function this statement
right over here so this is what we need
to prove in the case of this statement
right over here we're first going to
prove it for one that's going to be our
base case and then we're going to do the
induction step
the induction step which is essentially
saying if we assume it works for some
positive integer k
that if so if we assume that then we can
prove that it's going to work for the
next positive integer it's going to work
for k plus 1. and the reason why this
works let's say that we prove if we
prove both of this so the base case
we're going to prove it for in this case
we're going to prove for one
prove
for
one but there's it doesn't always have
to be one because you might your your
statement might be this is true for
everything above 55 or everything above
some threshold but in this case we're
saying it's true for all positive
integers so our pr our base case is
going to be for one
and then our induction step we're going
to try to prove that if you assume
if you assume
for
if you assume that this thing is true
sum of k
if we assume that then it is going to be
true for sum of k plus one and the
reason why this is all you have to do to
pro to prove this for all positive
integers is just imagine so let's let's
think about all of the positive integers
right over here one two
three four five six you could just keep
going on forever so we're going to prove
it for one we're going to prove that
this formula right over here this this
expression applies for the case of one
when n is one and then we're going to
prove that if we know it's true for any
given k that is true for the next one so
if we know it's true for one in our base
case then the second step this induction
step says well it must be true for 2
then because we proved generally if it's
true for k it's going to be true for k
plus 1. well if it's true for 2 then it
must be true for 3 because we've proven
if it's true for if it's true for k it's
true for k plus 1. so if it's true for 2
it's true for 3. and then if it's true
for three it needs to be true for four
and you can just keep going on and on
forever which means it is true for
everything now spoken in general
generalities let's actually prove this
by
by induction so let's take
let's take
the sum
let's do this function on one well
that's just going to be the sum of all
positive integers including one is just
literally going to be one we've just
added all of them it's just one there's
no other positive integer up to and
including one and we can prove that this
is the same thing as
one times one plus one
all of that over two one plus one is two
two divided by two is one one times 1 is
1. so this formula right over here this
expression it worked for it worked for
1. so we proved we've proven our base
case we've proven it for 1.
now what i want to do is i want to
assume that it works for
some number for for some number k so i
will assume
i will assume
true
for
i will assume it is true for some number
k so i'm going to assume that for some
number k
that this function at k is going to be
equal to k times k plus 1
over 2. so i'm just assuming this is
true for that
now what i want to do is think about
what happens when i try to find when i
try to find this function for k plus 1.
so this is what i am assuming
i'm assuming i know this
now let's try to do it for k plus 1.
so what is the sum of all of the
integers up to and including k plus one
up to and including k plus one well this
is going to be one plus two plus three
plus all the way up to
k
plus k plus one right this is the sum of
everything up to and including k plus
one
well we're assuming that we know what
this already is we're assuming that we
already have a formula for this we're
assuming that this is going to simplify
to k
times k plus one
over two we're assuming that we know
that and so we'll just take this part
and we'll add it to k plus one
so we'll add it to the k plus one over
here
we'll add it to the k plus one and if
you find a common denominator if you
find a common the common denominator is
going to be 2
so this is going to be equal to
i'll write the part in magenta first
this is k
times k plus 1 over 2
plus
times k plus 1
over 2. this thing in blue is the same
thing as that thing in blue the 2's
would cancel out i just wrote it this
way so i have a common denominator and
so this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to we have a
common denominator of 2 and i'll write
this in a different color here so we're
going to have k
times k plus 1
plus 2 times k plus 1.
now at this step right over here you can
factor out a k plus one both of these
terms are divisible by k plus one so
let's factor this out so if you factor
out a k plus one you get k plus one
k plus one times
we're factoring it out over here if you
factor out a k plus 1 you just have a k
over here if you factor out a k plus 1
you just have a 2 let me color code
those so you know what i'm doing so this
is this 2 right over there
and this k
this k
is this k
is this k right over there we factored
it out
this these these k plus ones we factored
them out to this k plus one right over
there and it's going to be all of this
all of this over 2.
now we can rewrite this this is the same
thing this is equal to
this is the same thing as
this is the same thing as k plus 1
that's this part right over here times
k plus 1
k plus 1 plus 1 right this is clearly
the same thing as k plus 2
all of that over
all of that over 2. now why is this
interesting to us well we've just proven
it if we assume that this is true if we
assume that this is true and if we and
then we you just use that assumption
just use that assumption we get that the
sum of all the positive integers up to
including k plus 1 is equal to k plus 1
times k plus 1 plus 1 over 2. we're
actually showing that that original
formula that original formula applies to
k plus 1 as well if you just take k plus
1 and put it in for n
you put it in for n you got exactly the
result that we got over here so we
showed we prove we've proven our base
case this this this expression worked
for the sum for all of the positive
integers up to including one and it also
works if we assume that it works for
everything up for up for up to k or if
we assume it works for the integer k it
also works for the integer k plus one
and we're done that's our proof by
induction that proves to us that it
works for all positive integers why is
that well we we've proven it for one and
we've proven it that if it works for
some integer it's going to work for the
next integer if you can assume it works
for some integer it will work for the
next integer so if you assume that it
worked for one then it can work for two
well we've already proven that it works
for one so we can assume it works for
one so it definitely will work for two
so we get two checked but since we can
assume it works for two we can now
assume it works for three well if it
works for three well then we've proven
that it works for four and you see how
this induction step is kind of like a
domino and it cascades and we can go on
and on forever so it'll really work for
all positive integers